et vous avez une révélation à nous faire
oui concernant la triche dans les jeux
auj
attention le dossier alors le socialiser
la banque était benjamin et les équipes
en france c'est le niveau des questions
est assistée me regardez pas comme ça
christian attentionné question va
apprendre des choses est ajustée en
fonction des gains dans nombre de jeux
que nous avons listé si la production
veut que le candidat reste question
facile si la production veut que le
candidat par questions difficiles c'est
pas possible aux états unis pour éviter
la triche
les questions sont préalablement déposé
chez un huissier je pense qu'il a
complètement raison
alors moi je quand j'animais des jeux je
ne connaissais pas les questions qui
étaient posées ni les réponses mais j'ai
produit à des jeux télé c'est vrai que
quand j'ai été en et nike pour en faire
un et que j'ai dit elle a expliqué à la
production que je comptais évidemment
ajusté en fonction des gains la
difficulté des questions ils m'ont gardé
le cap parce que la basse est interdite
depuis quiz show on en a fait un film
oui on peut plus tricher en france on le
sait même dans les millions le chemin de
fer comme on dit des questions est
ajustable en fonction un de ce que
connaît le candidat s'il est très fort
en histoire on va pas le baudet
collection histoire et ainsi de suite ou
et qu'est-ce qu'il ya pas que vous avez
vu tout mathieu étaient les mêmes
participez vous avez vous même animer un
jeu l'académie des 9 à 8 tours souvient
crs et trois semaines en terre
j'étais en face de tout cela mon poste
j'ai pu durer gouttes
c'est beaucoup pour cette attention à ce
que vous ignorez y est non alors messi
si quelqu'un de la prod en fait avait
appelé ma chérie pour y participer comme
candidate elle y est allé voilà l'avait
déjà gagnée mot de passe tout ça donc
ali et a dit à quel jeu à laquelle 10 k
et avait le jeu la personne de la prod
lui dit écoute voilà tous tout va te
dire caroline diamant c'est vrai tous te
vas te dire je sais plus si c'est faux
donc à lhassa en tête
ok d'accord mon cas les avantages et le
jeu commence ella a choisi car ligne sur
un truc est en fait je le disais
caroline et fo dont elle se dit merde
donc on a on m'a piégé elle essaye avec
l'autre pareil s'il fallait dire
du coup on s'est dit ok je faire à ma
sauce en fait on voulait la faire perdre
clairement et en fait elle a fait à sa
sauce et elle a gagné
elle est allée jusqu'au bout vous la
voilà c'est que benjamin n'était
absolument merci mais je vous assure
non mais alors jean-pierre descombes
quiquet cagnina télé depuis la
préhistoire
non on entend 85 dinosaures en 87 j'ai
repris le schmilblick les semaines mais
j'étais en province et il y avait
mettons 100 personnes qui voulaient jeu
au schmilblick
je faisais donc un tirage au sort où je
me dis que c'est en fait un objet la
pose des questions de l'idée qu'elle ait
cet objet 100 personnes qui sont
persuadés d'avoir la réponse tirage au
sort avait évité et au moment de jouer
je voyais des gens qui s'écartent et
comme ça qu'ils sortaient des billets de
banque
ils achetaient les places pour passer
s'il n'avait pas été tirés au sort il
achetait la place parce qu'ils étaient
certains d'avoir le schmilblick
et ouvrir quelque chose qui vous fait
par rapport au jeu télévisé partie en
effet de aussi quand même jeu télévisé
bon malheureusement je n'ai pas gagné
mais quelle une banque sa large et moi
j'ai fait deux fois prendre sa place sur
france 2 avec nagui est mon premier
passage on m'a quand même posé une
question sur les couleurs d'un panneau 2
du code de la route
ah oui si les s'ils étaient ces
questions sont choisis en fonction des
candidats ils sont trompés sur vous et
sur votre aventure incroyable
ouais et vous fait quelques révélations
quand même sur les métiers du jeu alors
oui effectivement ce qu'a dit tristan
c'est vrai après il faut savoir tout
simplement que une question ne peut
difficilement être jugé simple ou
compliqué parce que c'est très variable
d'une personne à l'autre
moi on peut me poser des questions très
pointues sur l'histoire du tennis où les
jeux olympiques et ça va me paraître
facile et paradoxalement on peut aussi
me poser des questions sur la cuisine
lune
moi j'ai perdu la durée de temps qui
sont d'un oeuf tout le monde penserait
que c'était simple et moi non alors
après effectivement il pirata justement
comme l'a dit gilles ça j'en suis tout à
fait conscient et effectivement dans un
jeu avec champions récurrent on peut
aménager le parc ou si vous avez été
éliminés vous fêtez est éliminé début
janvier 2010 est donc ça fait deux ans
j'ai été nominée autant il me manquait
du temps parce que j'ai une réponse a
plus à donner mais vous vous en êtes
autonome vous avez été éliminés et mamou
c'était difficile s'est passé combien de
temps 3 à moi à moi à moi et vous dis
d'un motif justement que les gens vous
vous parlez de l'émission qu'on ne
pouvait pas répondre que vous avez été
exactement parce que on peut pas on
pouvait pas vendre la mèche mais ça a
été a ébruité assez vite mais pourtant
séparé chemin qui a vendu la mèche laval
a vendu la mèche la veille
oui en publiant assure sur son compte
facebook
un mot d'adieu alors que j'étais pas
encore diffusé et les mauvaises langues
disent que tf1 nous reprocher d'avoir
fait ça c'est une façon en fait de
retirer la voiture vers lui parce que
vous aviez pris trop de place dont je
reviens pas je suis quand même moins
populaire que jean luc reichmann
vous ne vous rendez vous au pied des
révélations encore de faire sur les
rails en est une oui
la maintenance que le monstre vous sera
plus intéressante vous emballez pas
quand même un second fleuve a rallongé
par carrière mais rappelez-vous
seulement jean pierre foucault et il
m'en voudra pas que ce soit avec des
candidats ou avec des célébrités
quand vous regardez bien qui veut gagner
des millions à chaque fois que la
personne qui est en face c'était
quelqu'un qui avait très peu d'argent ou
qu'ils allaient perdre à un petit niveau
ou même des célébrités pour une assos et
que la personne se trompait mais
regardez bien cesser c'est évident à
chaque fois c'était voulait pas prendre
un joker
ce serait pas plus prenants proches
choqués et surpris chez leurs hôtes et à
linverse quand la personne est la bonne
réponse
écoutez et cie ont validé à l'ovalie
mais c'est plutôt humain vous avez
quelqu'un de vous car rien qui arrive de
500 euros qui va perdre un petit montant
mais il les aidait à chaque fois alors
je vais je vais vous raconter la vérité
mais quand je faisais un contre sens sur
tf1 il y avait des candidats qui étaient
sympathiques d'autres étaient beaucoup
moins candide était pas sympathiques je
me précipitais pas pour lui de débris
revanche de code était très sympa où je
trouvais vraiment et je savais qu'il ait
besoin d'argent
une fois j'ai fait moi une grosse bêtise
et le producteur d'insultés où ils
allaient buzz et j'avais y avait trop de
heurts
abc où ils allaient peser sur le sait je
lui ai pris l'un pour l'enlever et ça il
faut pas le faire mais vous pensez bien
j'avais enlevé la main et je me suis
fait copieusement engueulé reconnaissait
que c'est humain c'est humain mais j'en
perds quand vous regardez beaucoup
d'émissions comme j'ai regardé c'est
c'est d'une évidence héros et dans ses
yeux